welcome to cs330 uh today we'll be
talking about offline reinforcement
learning and offline multitask
reinforcement learning and these are
some of the hottest parts of
reinforcement learning these days
there's a lot of progress happening in
these fields so it's a it's an exciting
topic
before we get started a reminder the
optional homework 4 is due next Monday
so uh hopefully you're already working
on that
cool so
if let's them out a little bit we talked
a little bit about multitask
reinforcement learning just
reinforcement learning meta
reinforcement learning but let's just
zoom out and kind of see what is the
recipe that has worked so far for
machine learning in general for modern
machine learning methods
so refer to zoom out far enough we need
two parts
we need a lot of data so for instance
the data set of a size of an imagenet
where we have million images
or large corporate of text like like we
had in the natural language processing
example
um or natural language processing case
uh all of Wikipedia for instance
and then we need expressive capable
models that are able to digest all of
that data
right so for computer vision
traditionally these have been
convolutional neural Nets
for natural language processing
Transformers now being used also on in
vision and many other applications
cool so let's see if
um the reinforcement learning recipe
fits into this
so the reinforcement learning recipe
looks like this
we need a lot of data and we need
expressive Capital models so instead of
in in terms of expressive capable models
it's relatively easy we can just we use
a similar libraries so we can use the
best the biggest advancements that we've
seen in Vision or in language and just
apply them to reinforcement learning so
we can use convolutional neural Nets we
can use Transformers that's fine
but then when it comes to data so far
the way that we've been discussing
reinforcement learning we have this Loop
where we are constantly generating data
for any given experiment
this is an active learning Loop where we
go into the world then we collect some
data with our with our agent then we fit
something to that data we try to learn
something from it and then we with this
new updated Network we go into the work
into the world and then collect more
data with the agent and we do it over
and over again
so this is a little bit different to the
supervised learning recipe where you can
just access a lot of data that's already
available out there here we do this
actively over and over again
and this is actually a limiting factor
when it comes to reinforcement learning
and the amounts of data we can Digest
so it's hard to achieve the same level
of generalization that we've seen in
supervised learning with this per
experiment Active Learning Loop
so what offline reinforcement learning
tries to do is try to get rid of this
active data collection Loop and instead
just access big data sets that were
collected offline assuming that we are
not able to collect any additional data
and this is what we're going to talk
about today and hopefully if we can do
that then we can able to access Big Data
says there's just a lot of data that was
collected offline and then see similar
exciting generalization results that
we've seen in supervised learning
all right so the plan for today is to
First discuss the offline rail problem
formulation
then talk about some solutions to this
problem
then we'll talk about offline multitask
for enforcement learning and how it
influence data sharing
and then we'll end an offline goal
condition reinforcement learning which
is a really exciting area of research
right now
all right cool let's start let's start
with the offline rail problem
formulation
so if you remember we had this anatomy
of a reinforcement learning algorithm
when we went through this a few times
now where we first generate samples then
we try to fit them all to estimate
return and we have a few different
options here either policy gradient Q
learning or we can use model-based
methods as well and then we have one
more box that tries to improve the
policy given that model that estimates
the return
so what we'll try to do in the offline
case is we'll we'll try to
move away from this pattern where we
keep generating data where we keep
generating samples by running the policy
and instead just access the data set
that's already already available to us
so the one thing that we are changing is
that we are not allowed to use this
Orange Box anymore
all right so in order to do this we can
use some of the algorithms that we
already know and we've learned about two
types of reinforcement learning
algorithms on policy and off policy
algorithms and this is just a quick
reminder slide of what the difference
between these two is
so for on policy algorithms data has to
come from the current policy so we are
constantly collecting data with the
precious policy that we have
it's compatible with all our algorithms
and we can't reuse data from previous
policies we from previous policies we
have to be collecting the data and using
the data from the policy that is the
most fresh
and for the off policy case data can
come from any policy we don't really
care what policy it was collected with
in the works of specific RL algorithms
such as value-based methods
and it's much more sample efficient
because we can reuse all data we can do
multiple gradient steps on the same data
all right so
so given these two do you have any any
uh idea which one we would use for the
offline case given these these these two
categoristics uh characteristics
yes
yeah so it's probably the off policy
case instead of data coming from a
policy we'll just use any data that's
right
all right so we'll be using off policy
URL
um but there is a small difference
between off policy RL and offline RL so
here's a little graphic explaining the
the difference
so in the off in the online
reinforcement learning just to reiterate
this we have a world that we can collect
data on we do rollouts on this world so
we get the next state and the reward
from the world then we can execute our
policy that gives us the actions and we
do multiple rollouts in this Loop
then we take that rollout data that that
we just generated and we update the
policy using that data and then we use
we push the new policy into the world to
collect more action to collect more
rollouts
in the off policy case there is one more
addition the addition of this replay
buffer where we can collect bunch of
rollouts and then the rollout data goes
into the buffer and that buffer now
consists of all the rollouts that we've
never that we've ever had right so it
doesn't just need to be the most fresh
rollout data this is any any rollout
that we've collected in the in the
history of this experiment
then we take samples from that buffer to
update our policy and then this updated
policy gets to execute and do uh
multiple rollouts in the real world
and now this is the offline
reinforcement learning case so in the
offline reinforcement learning case
we assume that the data collected is
only once with any policy and we will
call this policy Pi data policy of the
buffer we don't really know what's what
kind of policy this is this was
collected we didn't have access to it it
was collected before we even started
working on this experiment it's just we
have some data in the buffer already
so we have access to the buffer then we
can sample from the buffer and learn our
policy and we can use as many gradient
steps as we would like but we can't
really collect any additional data we
don't have access to the world to
collect additional data that can be used
for learning
so instead we'll be just sampling from
the buffer learning cover policy and
then once we are done we'll just deploy
it in the world and see how well it
works
all right so a few notations
here will be the the capital d symbol
will be referring to the SARS tuples
that we have in our uh in our replay
buffer so this is the state action next
state and the reward
then our states will come from the
marginal estate distribution of our
policy Pi data
and Pi beta is the policy that we have
in the buffer so we don't really know
what it is it's an unknown policy we
don't have any form of it we just have
access to samples from this policy and
this is what we have in the buffer right
so the actions that we see in the buffer
are the actions that were executed by
this unknown policy and the states that
we have in the buffer are the marginal
that the policy
and then there is a Dynamics model that
we don't have access to as well
in terms of the objective it's similar
to The Standard reinforcement learning
objective we were trying to maximize the
future sum of returns and find the arc
Max of the policy
so in this case we are summing over all
the time steps and then we are making we
are taking the expectation under the
state distribution that we see in the
buffer actions that we pick according to
our policy that we are learning right
now Pi Theta
and we're trying to maximize the sum of
return the discounted sum of returns
all right so given all this can you
think of any potential applications of
offline reinforced learning given the
differences to online of policy and so
on yes
right yeah right just to repeat the the
answer uh anytime where it's costly or
dangerous to collect additional data in
the environment for example in medical
applications or in dangerous
environments any any other ideas of
applications of offline reinforcement
learning
all right yeah so it's uh it basically
that covers I think most of the cases so
anytime when it's very difficult to
deploy the agent this was something
where we can just access the data that
was already collected or if it's very
difficult to collect that data in the
real world like for instance as you said
in the medical applications this could
be extremely useful and we can find ways
to learn from that already collected
data to act better in the future even
better than the policy that collected
the data
right so speaking about offline
reinforcement learning and what it can
be used for what can it actually do how
can it work that you can just access
some data that was collected previously
by some policies and you can somehow
extract something from it
so it can do three things so first it
can just find best behaviors in a data
set so if you have a bunch of different
behaviors that was collected by
different policies it can just pick
which ones were the best and just use
those and that's relatively simple
secondly it can also generalize these
best behaviors to similar situations so
here we are training this whole thing
with deep neural networks which can
generalize quite well so if we've seen
that something worked in a particular
situation now because of the
generalization properties of neural
networks we'll be able to apply similar
behaviors in similar situations through
generalization
and then thirdly it can also stitch
together parts of good behaviors into
even a better behavior and this is maybe
a little bit less intuitive so here's a
little example if we had two
trajectories in the buffer one that goes
from A to B and another one that goes
from B to C and we wanted to find the
best way that goes from the shortest
path that goes from a to c it should be
able to stitch this trajectories such
that it uses the first part of
trajectory from A to B and the second
part of the trajectory from B to C
stitch them together and get a much
better trajectory than either one of the
ones that we've collected before
and it can do the stitching because of
dynamic programming properties of of
offline reinforcement learning
or another case where we have two points
we need to get from this point to that
point and we have lots of noisy
trajectories that we collected that go
between these points or sometimes don't
even don't even touch any of these
points right just lots of noisy
trajectories that were somewhat
collected offline reinforcement learning
should be able to stitch these behaviors
to find the policy that finds the
shortest path between these two points
right so we can learn a policy that is
better than the data that then the
policy that the data was collected with
all right so we talked we said that we
could use off policy algorithms to to
solve this problem that are more
applicable than on policy algorithms
because they can use any data
so let's try it we learned about this
fitted QE iteration algorithm
it more or less went like this
we have a few algorithm hyper parameters
we have a data set size a collection
policy and then we are trying to learn a
q function that takes as input State and
action and outputs a q value a scalar
that tells us what's the predicted sum
of Rewards
and then we are iterating we are doing
gradient steps on on this objective
right here we're trying to fit the Q
function to the Target and the target is
uh is the reward plus the max over
action of the next queue so this is
um this is the main equation that we use
for this for the target of our Q
function
so we do this over K iterations and then
we'll continue collecting the data set
using some policy and do this
iteratively
after we do this we can get the policy
by just using the arcmax over actions
from the queue
all right so a few nodes have been noted
while we were introducing it we can
reuse data from previous policies right
so we can use any policy here we still
do this iteratively but you can imagine
that we just want to do this Loop we'll
just access that data set and we will
not collect additional data
and it's an off it was an off policy
algorithm so we can use replay buffers
to to sample the data from
and it was not a gradient the sun
algorithm it was a dynamic programming
algorithm
so
one question I have to use do you
remember what this equation was called
this equation that we compute Q targets
with
the Belmont equation that's right yeah
Belmont optimality equation and this is
a really important equation so we'll get
back to it in a second
all right so this is the fitted
iteration algorithm
and then we talked about how we can
apply this with the Belmont equation
to a robotic application to grasping and
Achieve pretty good results so the way
it worked it was described in this paper
called qtop where we would store data
from all the past experiments
then we would have a buffer that that
has all the off policy experiences in
addition to this would collect a little
bit of on-policy data and have a
separate buffer for that
and then we'll try to train the skew
function
we'll have a set of jobs that run in
parallel that compute development
updates so they run the Belmont equation
inside of there they're also doing
cross-entropy minimization to find this
Max over a continuous action space
and then as the result of the Belmont
update we get the label pairs that are
then being put in the training job to
actually apply the gradients to the
network
and this actually worked
um quite well so uh this we used seven
rubbers that collected over 580
000 grasps and on unseen test objects we
were able to see some really cool
generalization behaviors where the robot
was able to singulate the object uh do
some regrasping behavior and actually
grasp a lot of them
the result that I reported back then a
few weeks ago was 96 percent
so we were able to grasp previously
unseen objects with 96 success rate
but there's a little caveat that they
didn't tell you about
so this 96 this result was achieved with
this data set it was 580 000 offline
trajectories
plus a very small portion of online
trajectories as well so it's 28 000
trajectories collected online
and that's what led to 96 percent
now we also evaluated the performance of
the system only on the 580 000 offline
trajectories without any online data
collection all right so this is the
offline off uh sorry offline
reinforcement learning case there is no
on policy data collection whatsoever
and you can tell that you know the
fraction of online data collection is so
small that it's very unlikely that this
small fraction of data the small
additional data set has uh suddenly you
know boosted generalization in some
crazy way it's probably if it if it
helped it's probably because of the fact
that it's online not because of the fact
that it's 28 000.
so if you run just this just on this
data and we apply our QT of the
algorithm we get the result of 87
percent
and it might seem not that big of a
difference but if you look at the error
rate here the error rate is four percent
here the errors is 13 so basically uh we
can cut it in three times right but with
just extra 25
000
um online trajectories
so there is something going on here
where the online data collection is
really really important and it can boost
our results significantly
um so let's take a look at what's going
on in the offline case why isn't working
why why isn't it isn't it working as
well as it should
right so let's talk about some offline
the rental the problem and the and the
solutions
all right so in terms of the problem we
talked about the main equation in Q
learning the develman equation
so just to repeat we say that the
optimal Q function is equal to this
expectation over dynamics of the reward
at the current step plus the max of the
Q function at the next step
so let's analyze this situation that we
had in the previous slide and we'll
analyze it on this half cheetah
environment it's a popular environment
used in reinforcement learning
so the way we would analyze it is the
following we would collect a bunch of
trajectories while we are training this
agent to run forward as fast as possible
and we'll train it on policy or using an
off policy algorithm that will collect
data in the meantime and we can get it
to a mediocre performance that achieves
the performance of around 5000 that's
the reward that it gets
and then we'll take that data set that
RL Trace so all the data that that agent
generated and then we'll try to learn
the same policy by by using an offline
RL algorithm
all right so here are the two important
graphs
so this shows the average return over
the number of gradient steps if we take
that RL trace and if we change the the
amount of data that we have access to so
we can either generate just you know a
thousand trajectories or I think in this
case Source tuples or ten thousand or a
hundred thousand or a million of them
and we can look at the average turn
Return of the agent that is training
from the data set offline
and remember the policy that was
collecting the data was achieving the
reward of over six thousand here we are
at around zero or actually below zero
so you're not learning anything really
right even though we have data that
definitely has some trajectories that
can achieve higher return
um our off offline reinforcement
learning algorithm is not able to
extract that
and then here on the on the right
there's another plot which shows the log
of the Q function so basically it tries
to answer the question how well does the
does our offline reinforcement learning
algorithm thinks it does
so this this Plus on the left tells us
how well it actually does and it doesn't
do very well
and the plot on the right tells us how
well it it thinks it does right and we
can see that uh it actually thinks that
it's getting better and better for all
of these cases
right so there's something going on here
so does anybody have any idea what what
might be wrong
yes
that's a great question so why is it
that for a smaller number of samples we
get higher Q function
yeah I'm sure
yeah at this point we don't know it's a
good question
yes
so in this case even if we make the
reverse nuts bars I think actually in
half cheetah there are not sparse
um it's still we can't really get a good
behavior for using offline reinforcement
learning good idea though yes
right so
um just to repeat the the answer it's
probably overestimating how well it's
doing for the Q function because that
Max term over here is probably sampling
some actions that we've never seen
before and it thinks that those actions
are doing really well
yeah so that's that's a that's a really
good answer so there is something going
on with this Max term that is causing
our algorithm to to not do very well or
our Q function to be overly optimistic
so let's analyze it a little bit a
little bit further
all right so this is a rebellion
equation
and now let's imagine that we are trying
to fit our
um to our our neural network to a True Q
function which is what we're trying to
do and let's try to plot it like this so
the True Q function here is the plotting
in green this is the True Q function
that we are trying to fit to
and then we are doing a decent job with
with trying to fit to it and our fitted
curve is the one in blue
all right so it's a little bit off here
and there but overall we are doing a
fairly decent job
right so now this term right here this
Max over actions for
um our learn Q function we'll try to fit
we'll try to find the max for the blue
function right so in this case the max
will be this peak that we have right
there
all right and the problem with the
speaker is that basically the our Q
learning algorithm will try to find the
max no matter what right so it will it
will look for the Peaks even though
these Peaks might not be real so it's
kind of looking for the the uh the part
of the function where the posit where we
have the biggest positive error
right because it's just trying to find
the max
so in a sense Q learning is an
adversarial algorithm it's trying to
find the the biggest error that we have
in the currently fitted Q function which
is the biggest positive error
and the reason why this way this is
happening is because we don't know the
value of the actions that we haven't
taken we don't know the counter factuals
so if you see all the data that was
collected by some policy it's really
hard to tell you know what would have
happened had they taken this other
action what kind of return would I have
gotten
so it's exactly as the as the previous
answer this Max of our actions can query
some actions that we've never seen
before and that leads to a distribution
shift
and then Q learning will pick those
actions because of the max operator
all right so one question is what
happens in the online case how come this
is not a problem in the online case yes
our little taste like this than in the
Next Generation with them after the
report will be seen a little thing added
and so it is yeah that's right yeah so
in the online case just repeat the
answer
um we would we would still think that
this is the the best action to take but
in the next iteration we'll actually
take that action and then we'll see that
the reward for that action is not that
high and then we'll fit the script a
little bit better we'll push it down
because we'll just experience that the
reward isn't as high and this this
online kind of active correction process
will make sure that our Q function is is
correct
in the offline case we don't have access
to that we can't really correct for
these errors
all right so let's think about some some
solutions to offline oral problems and
first we'll talk about the explicit set
of solutions and then about some
implicit sort of solutions that seem to
work a little better
so just to reiterate the problem on a
slightly different plot here we have on
the on the y-axis the value of the queue
and on the x-axis we have the action
that we pick
and let's say that if we were to plot
the distribution of the actions that we
see in the buffer of Pi beta it will
look like this dashed Red Line all right
so we have these actions that we've
actually experienced and if we were to
fit a policy to it it would probably
look like this all right this dashed Red
Line
so then we can try to fit our Q function
the blue line to this
and it will probably work fairly well
based on the actions that we've seen
but then it would be completely crazy
for anything else right like we don't
have any constraint there we don't know
what these actions should result in so
it will just it will experience the
distribution shift
now the biggest pick pick will be used
for the backups right
so what we need is some kind of some
kind of constraint right we need to
somehow tell our Q function to not use
these these Peaks right here because we
don't really have support for those
peaks in our data so you can only pick
the peak of your Q function that is
supported by what we have seen in the
buffer
so we can optimize our Q function or
optimize the sum of the returns but with
this with this additional constraint
saying that our policy that we're trying
to learn should be relatively close to
the policy that we have in the buffer
right so we are not able to deviate from
that policy we have to stay close to it
we can only pick among those
so now we have a few different options
on how to implement this constraint
one option is to use a KL Divergence
constraint so this is a way of measuring
the distance between two distributions
so we can measure explicitly the
distance between our policy and the
policy of the buffer
and then we can also use another
constraint a constraint that says that
these two policies should have the same
support they don't have to be the same
distributions they don't have to be
close in terms of the distributions but
they should have the same support so
whenever our the policy can be the
probability of some actions can be
larger than zero only if the probability
of the same actions under our buffer
policy is larger than Epsilon
right and these two differences the the
difference between the Cal Divergence
constraint and the support constraint
are actually quite significant
so if we were to do distribution
matching so KL diversions constraint
that means that we could only pick
um
policies that are very similarly looking
to the policies that we have seen in the
buffer all right so these are these
purple policies that you see right here
these will be the policies that have
relatively small scale
KL Divergence between the buffer policy
and the policy that we're learning
however when we use the support
constraint we can use any policy as long
as it has the same support as our policy
in the buffer so now it can be much more
peaky it can be you know much sharper as
but as long as it has the same support
we are okay
all right
do you have uh do you have any
suggestions as to which one would be
better
which one would be better to use the
support constraint or the KL Divergence
constraint
foreign
yeah that's correct so with the support
of the distribution matching one you're
uh you're quite conservative right you
can be only as good as the policy that
you've seen in the buffer but here we
can see that this action is definitely
much better than these two so maybe we
might want to be a little bit sharper
right we want to make our gaussian a
little bit more uh picky like this one
but we wouldn't be able to do that
because of the KL Divergence constraint
so the support the support constraint
does not ask conservative and allows us
to do a little bit more
it is however a little bit harder to
implement so people usually in this
explicit methods refer to the KL
Divergence constraint
all right cool so
there are some methods that that
actually do this and here are some
references but they actually don't work
that well because of explicit
representation of this pipe data is
actually quite tricky so the most modern
motor methods do this implicitly and
I'll discuss two of them
so again this is our function and we're
trying to find the the max the policy
that maximizes the queue subject to this
constraint so that we have to be close
to our PI data
so this is a constraint optimization
problem that we can actually solve via
like Branch multipliers by a duality
and I won't go for the whole derivation
of this but if you're interested there
it was actually derived a few times in a
few different papers but I think one of
the most accessible ones is the one
described by Jan Peters at all in the
paper called wraps relative entropy
policy
something policy optimization
all right so the result of this equation
looks like this so our optimal policy is
equal to the policy of the buffer that
we don't have access to right so the
policy of the buffer that is
exponentially weighted by the advantage
of our policy
all right
so we can actually implement this and
I'll tell you a little bit about the
intuition of what this actually means in
a second
so if we were to implement this it would
look like this our new policy
would be equal to the max likelihood
objective right we are trying to fit our
policy using the samples from the buffer
so at this point we are just doing
Behavior Chrome cloning if we didn't
have these terms right here
okay this is we are just trying to fit
our policy to whatever we've seen in the
buffer
but then additionally we waited by some
weight
all right so there are some weights that
depends on State and action
and then this weight is exponentiated
Advantage so what that means is that we
would need to estimate our advantage
function which tells us how good is an
action compared to all the other actions
and then we'll put a little bit more
weight on the actions that are better in
terms of our advantage so I'll do this
weight at maximum likelihood where we
won't just copy all the actions that
will say that the actions will have
better Advantage functions should have a
little bit higher weight we want to do
these actions more
and this is actually implemented in this
algorithm called Advantage weighted
regression as well as this algorithm by
Ashwin Nair at all called awake
all right
so there's one more algorithm yes
there's a question
yeah so this is a normalization constant
which usually we treat as a hyper
parameter
that's a great question so the repeated
question so is that so far we rely that
our PI beta has to be good enough so
that we can find a really good solution
given our support in pi data so how do
we make sure that pay beta is really
good we're done so we are trying to find
the best policy we can the best possible
policy given Pi beta right so we just
have access to some data set and we will
try to get the best make the best do the
best job we can given that data set
right and if the data set isn't very
good then our policy won't be very good
but hopefully it will be still quite
good
all right so here's
um another solution an implicit Solution
that's actually fairly straightforward
that seems to be working really really
well yes
um
yeah so the question is is there an
upper bound how well you can do given Pi
beta
um
I believe
the I think it's really tricky to find
that upper bound because of the way that
it can be stitched it's actually really
tricky to find out what's the best
possible policy you can do you there is
a problem in offline reinforcement
learning that talks about how you can
rank different policies given the data
set but I'm not sure if you can
apprehend it yeah it's a great question
all right cool so there's one more
solution to this problem there's an
implicit solution that actually works
really well and it's relatively
straightforward and it's called
conservative Q learning and this was
introduced by Avril Kumar in 2020.
so it works as following so we have our
functions as usual
and now we have this peak that was a
problem right so this was the peak that
was just the max of our actions for our
queue
um for our Q function
so what we can do is we can take that
Peak right we know that PKS this is what
we do in our Q Target computation for
permanent equation
and we can just push it down we can just
say every Peak that we find let's just
push the value of it down
right
so let's try to do this so this is the
equation for cql this conservative Q
learning it might be a little
complicated but it's actually fairly
straightforward so this second part here
this is just standard Q learning so here
we are just saying that our current
queue the difference between our current
q and the reward plus the Queue at the
next state should be minimized all right
so this is just minimizing them on there
but we have this additional term right
here
in this additional term right here is
saying that we should be pushing down
big Q values so here we are trying to
maximize the policy so we are trying to
find the policy that maximizes the queue
right so this is the policy that takes
up Max and then we say take those Q
values and push them down
right so find those Peaks and push each
one of them down
and you can do this and it actually
already Works quite okay and you can
then show that the uh this Q function
computed with with this equation is uh
um it's upper bounded by the by the True
Q function right because we're pushing
kind of all the values down
so there's
um it already kind of works but there's
one more problem with it in that you're
pushing everything down right so
including some points that we're
actually seeing in the data
so you can actually do a small
modification to it and add one more term
so here we are pushing down big Q values
but in addition to this we'll add this
other term that will be pushing up
everything that we've seen in the data
right so here is this is added with the
negative term as a negative term so we
are pushing up we're minimizing this
whole thing so we are pushing this up
and we are sampling actions from our
data set and we're saying uh push up the
Q values of everything that we've
actually seen the data
so what this amounts to is that we want
to push everything down that we haven't
seen in the data and if we have seen
anything in the data we'll push it back
up
right so for things that we've actually
seen in the data these two terms will
cancel out and we'll just do our normal
equation
all right so
um this is the the final equation that
we would use in cql
and the intuition is the following so
before what we had is we this is another
plot of showing in the x axis the Q
value on the x-axis our actions and then
this is our true actual Q function and
let's say we have a very small action
support in our data set this is the the
actions that we've seen Pi beta
so if you were to fit a naive Q function
it will do a decent job in the action
support case but everywhere else it will
be a little bit wild and we'll pick the
wrong values for our Max operator
so in the cql case we'll fit this
conservative Q function that will be
conservative anywhere where we haven't
seen any data right so where we don't
have action support our conservative
queue function here in blue will be a
little bit lower than the actual Q
function and this is okay we want to be
kind of pessimistic in this case
however during the act in the action
support will be relatively well fitted
and sometimes we will not underestimate
those values sometimes we might
overestimate them a little bit but that
might be good enough for us to have a
good Q function
all right so let's see how it works so
we can actually implement it fairly
easily we can just update our queue
function according to this loss that we
just described where we sample data from
our data set and we update the policy
and we enter it
and this algorithm was actually tested
on three different data sets one
consists of this little ant
robot that is navigating in a maze
there's another set of environments
where there were collected some
demonstrations and they were doing some
manipulation skills
and another one where we had a Franca
robot that was deployed in a in a
simulated kitchen and had to do a bunch
of different things as well
and here are the different results
showing all kinds of different Baseline
comparisons so you can do behavioral
cloning you can do some popular self
actual critic algorithms other explicit
methods for offline reinforcement
learning and you can see that cql here
this part this cql is the one that
pushes down the high the actions that
achieve high or pushes down the Q values
of actions that we haven't seen and also
has this additional term that pushes up
the actions that we have seen
and you can see that this one works much
better across the board than all the
other algorithms and it's relatively
simple yes there is a question
is
so the question was does SAC have access
to online interactions no so all of them
have access just to the offline data set
yeah
actions
[Music]
our outside reaction support because
excellent guarantee that those Q values
are going to be lower than the two
values for actions inside the support or
is it still possible for those actions
to have like a high Q value then after
that turn yeah that's a great question
um yeah so it does guarantee that at the
guarantees that because we'll be pushing
all of them down that they'll eventually
be lower than the ones that we see in
the action support and there's actually
proof in the paper showing that great
question
right cool are there any other questions
at this point
cool all right
so we learned about some solutions to
this offline reinforcement learning
problem we know what the problem
actually is we know how we can
regularize it a little bit better so
that we can find policies that are
better than the policies that we uh that
we've uh that we've collected before
all right so let's let's think a little
bit about multitask reinforcement
learning and how it works in the offline
multitask case
so we talked already about multitask
reinforcement learning algorithms and we
talked about how it's relatively easy to
to take an existing reinforcement
learning algorithm make it a multitasker
enforcement learning algorithm we can
just add an additional task identifier Z
that tells us which task we're in and we
can add it as part of the state so we
can then change the policy to be
conditioned on the task
uh similarly we can change the Q
function to be conditioned on the task
and then we said that there's one
difference with reinforcement learning
where in addition to sharing weights
between different tasks we can also
control the data distribution so in
addition to sharing weights we can also
share the data
right so we can take data generated by
one task and relabel it as data that
would have come from another task
and then we went for this one example
of multitask Q learning applied to
robotics called empty up this is the
multitask extension of qtm that we
discussed before
and it worked as following there's this
little GIF where we collect an episode
that episode is labeled as successor
failure and then we can impersonate it
or relabel it for other tasks that are
Successful Failure and then use those
episodes for all the other tasks and
then take a stratified batch and use it
for multitasker learning
and then we can learn many different
manipulation tasks and we talk a little
bit about the the average Improvement
that we get over training single tasks
and how it improves more the tasks that
have very little data and how we can
quickly fine tune your tasks using data
collecting new data that we require just
one day of data collection and get
really high performance on a task we
haven't seen before
but there was there was one thing that I
mentioned when we were talking about
this which is the way we impersonate
these tasks so when we get the episode
and when we have to decide whether this
episode will be reliable for this task
or that one or all of them or none of
them this decision actually matters and
it matters a lot and at that time when
we were working on this algorithm we
didn't understand that
right so we just realized that it's
subtle if you share data across all of
the tasks it doesn't work very well if
you've shared if you don't share data at
all it doesn't work very well either but
if you share data using some heuristics
sometimes it works really well
all right so let's see if we can use our
offline RL expertise now to maybe
decipher this a little bit to see what's
going on
right so we want to answer the question
whether we can share data across
um across distinct tasks so we'll do
this in a in a slightly smaller
environment so we can understand a
little bit better
so we'll be mixing data from three
different policies we have this 2D
Walker and we collected data where it
tries to run forward when it runs
backward and when it jumps and then we
put all of these data together
all right so these are the different
data set sizes for these different runs
and here we vary a little bit how we
collected the data so sometimes we would
get a performance that is mediocre and
we'll take the entire replay buffer that
got us to the performance
and then we'll mix it all together and
then we'll see if we don't share the
data versus where we share all the data
what's the difference in the performance
so in this case for these data sets it
seems like if we don't share the data
it's a little bit better than if we do
share data across all the tasks
now if we use slightly different replay
buffers then it seems like the opposite
is true sharing the data is actually
much better than not sharing the data at
all
and then if we pick another combination
it seems like average performance is yet
again better for no sharing than for
sharing across all the data and it's
especially true for the tasks where we
try to jump
right where we use actually the expert
data set
all right so remember that you know we
still have everything that applies to
offline reinforcement learning right so
we have an unknown buffer policy Pi beta
so this is a little peculiar right like
there's no it's it's really hard to tell
what's going on here sometimes it helps
to share data like in this case
sometimes it's it really hurts sometimes
it's better not to share sometimes it
depends on what task you're evaluating
it on
so let's look a little bit more into it
so it seems that sharing data generally
helps but it can hurt performance in
some cases
so can we characterize why it hurts
performance
so then we added one more
um one more plot one more number that we
started measuring so we actually
explicitly fit the behavioral cloning
policy to what we had in the buffer we
did this explicit method and then we
tried to
um then we computed the KL Divergence
between our policy and the policy that
we have in the buffer
and then you can see that especially for
for this case right here when we share
the data right when we share the data
across all the tasks the KL diversions
between the policy that we have in the
buffer and our policy is huge right
we're far much further away from that
policy that if we were just if we're not
sharing data at all
right
so do you have any idea why why that
could be the case
yeah this is this is a little tricky
it's a difficult question
right well we'll think about it some
more but the main hint is that
sharing data accessor base distribution
ship that we talked about before
all right all right so let's talk a
little bit about how how it happens
and uh so sharing data while so sharing
data does exacerbate the distribution
shift so we'll try to minimize this but
we'll first explain why that happens
so to do this let's introduce one small
piece of notation
we will assume that relabeling data from
some task J right here depicted as DJ
to task I generates a data set dj2i
which is then additionally used to train
on task I alright so we can take data
from task J and relabel it to task I and
this is we'll depict it with this symbol
here
and then the effective data set for task
I after relabeling will be then given by
the data set that we had for that task
plus everything that we labeled from
task J to task I
right so we kind of expanded the data
set for that task as you did in homework
3 for instance
okay cool
so what this means is that now because
we decide
what kind of data set this task will
have right like we decide what kind of
tasket or which episodes get relabeled
to task I
we now get to control the data set
ourselves or the behavior policy the
policy of the buffer ourselves
right does that make sense this is
actually quite insightful uh
quite a good Insight here
right so we have we still have a fixed
data set that was collected from many
different tasks but now we can morph
this data set into something else
because we can take some data collected
by one task and relabel it to another
task so we'll change the distribution of
the data collected by this other task
right
cool are there any questions to that
does that make sense
all right cool so this is now the first
time where we can actually control
what's in the data set in a sense by
relabeling things
cool so so let's use that fact to to try
to think about what's happening in this
in this multitask offline reinforcement
learning
all right so in the standard offline
reinforced learning if we were to kind
of simplify our objective it would look
like this we are trying to maximize the
reward right according to our data set
so we're trying to find the policy that
maximizes this but then in addition to
this we have this regularizer towards
the data Behavior policy
um so the policy that we see in the
buffer Pi beta
right so this is the regularizer that
we've been talking about
okay
so then now so far we've been just
trying to optimize for the best policy
that we can find
that will optimize this entire equation
right we assume that we have no control
over Pi beta
but we do have control over pipe better
so here we'll change the objective a
little bit and we'll say the following
in addition to finding the arc Max in
addition to finding our policy now here
we are operating not on just data set
that we've seen But actually this
effective data set that includes the
tasks that we were labeled to
we'll also be able to find the best data
so optimize for the effective Behavior
policy to maximize the reward and
minimize the distribution shift so we
are just now adding this additional knob
that we not only have to or can optimize
our policy but we can also change what
the data distribution looks like right
and this is this is depicted by this Pi
beta and this point beta here and the
fact that our data set is now being
changed by how we reliable the tasks
okay so now we can actually introduce a
very simple way of sharing data that
should probably help so it's called
conservative data sharing
and we'll share data only when
conservative Q value will increase for
that task
so what this means is the following
this is the data that we would relabel
to task I so and we can compute the Q
function for that state and action pair
and we can compare it to the Q function
for the state and action pair from the
data set for that task
and if and if it's better then we can
use that we can relabel to that task
right so we can then pick and choose
which episode should be reliable to
other tasks which shouldn't and we do
this based on our conservative Q value
so we can take an episode that was that
was generated by some tasks and then
based on this equation we can decide
should this episode be uh pushed into
the buffer for this task or this tasks
or some other task
very interesting question
yeah the key functions we're using is
the current estimate of task I it's a
conservative key function so we're using
cql
135
yeah that's like that's a great question
so the question is we might have added
some previous transitions based on our
back then estimate of the Q function and
we now remove them yeah so it's true we
can so as we are iterating over the data
set and we kind of decide every time how
to share the data the decision changes
over the time of training so we might
find that initially it's better to share
data across all of the different tasks
but later on maybe we should only share
among these tasks or something like that
that's correct yeah so you're always
deciding for any given State action pair
how to relabel it so every time you see
it you have to decide and you what kind
of what task you should relabel it to
all right so um you know we can
implement this we can implement this
conservative data sharing algorithm and
then see whether it prevents this this
additional distribution should
so first we start saying that if we do
implement this we see that the KL
Divergence between our policy and the
policy that we see in the buffer
actually goes down significantly
especially for this jump problem that we
had before
so it seems that it reduces the kale
Divergence between the data distribution
and the learn policy so that's already a
plus
but this also translates to improved
performance
so for this walker 2D case the CDs
the CDs algorithm is able to achieve the
best result
right in addition to this we also tried
to send this Vision based manipulation
task that we're actually the simulated
tasks that we use in empty opt
so the tasks included things like
picking things up putting them on the
ball and things like this things that we
also had in in the real world for empty
art experiments
and we run a few comparisons one
comparison is to this work called hippie
where we decide how to share tasks based
on the highest return so we'll only
share the episode with another task if
this other task would result in high
reward
and then we also compare to this
heuristic that we designed for empty opt
which we call the a skill based
heuristic so we'll just kind of pick the
tasks that we thought should be sharing
data and we just set it manually
and then we can see that across the
board CDs is much better than any of
these equivalents it's also better than
sharing data across all the tasks or not
sharing data at all
so it seems that we can take the tools
that we just learned about from offline
reinforcement learning and then use
these tools to understand better what's
going on in multitask reinforcement
learning whether it's online or offline
and understand better the underlying
problem and then use these tools to
design better task sharing algorithms or
task free labeling algorithms that then
help the overall performance
all right cool so we talked about
offline multitask oral and how it
influences data sharing are there any
questions at this point
all right
so now the uh the the last part which is
offline goal condition reinforcement
learning which I believe is one of the
most exciting Parts in reinforcement
learning these days so uh I'm
particularly excited about this topic if
you have any questions please shout out
and uh we'll try to go through this and
hopefully I can get across by my
excitement about this
all right so we talk a little bit about
goal condition reinforcement running
with hindsight pre-labeling that was the
topic of homework 3.
and the way it worked was the following
we were collecting some data using some
policy where the the reward was
associated with the goal that we wanted
to achieve
and then it would store that data in the
replay buffer
and then we can perform additional
hindsight relabeling where we can
relabel the experience in the data that
we just collected where we can use last
state as the goal so we can kind of
pretend that this was the plan that we
wanted to get to and then we can relabel
it with that reward
and started relabel data in the replay
buffer and then update the policy using
this
all right we also talked about other
labeling strategies how we can use any
state from and trajectory not just the
last state and relabel to that
so now the question is
what happens if we do it fully offline
all right
and now a little
okay A little little caveat to this is
that if we can do this fully offline
what does that mean
so that means that now we can take any
data set right any data set that has
some trajectories in it it just needs to
have States and actions it doesn't need
to have rewards right it doesn't we
don't need to collect additional data
for it
um it doesn't need to have tasks nothing
like this we can just take any data set
that has trajectories
and apply this hindsight goal condition
offline reinforcement learning algorithm
that we'll design in a second to it and
learn something from it right we can
combine multiple data sets we we kind of
remove tons of requirements that we had
before where we needed to have rewards
we needed to have tasks and all these
other things now we don't need any of
this right we can just take any data set
relabel all the states that we've
accomplished to the goal States and then
use offline reinforcement learning we
don't need any online interactions and
learn from all of that
yes there's a question
yeah so the rewards we can just
automatically set based on the states
that we've actually achieved so we can
just set that the reward function is
very simple it's a sparse reward
function that says if you got to that
state you get reward one and otherwise
you get reward zero and we can do this
for any any data set so in a sense we're
doing it rewards but we kind of we can
design them on on a spot
we don't need the reward function that
was used for the data
so this was this would finally put us in
this situation where we can access lots
of data lots of big data sets that are
out there that we used in supervised
learning then we can also do this for
reinforcement learning
all right so let's talk about how we can
do this and this is the work that was
done by Evan schebetter
um called actionable models
and the motivation for this work was
actually a little bit different so the
motivation for this work was the
following we had this data set that we
collected with empty up to where we had
the robot doing all kinds of different
things
and we wanted to scale up the number of
tasks that the robot was doing so here
we use 12 ablation tabs we got to maybe
16 or 20 tasks or so on but at some
point we realized that actually when we
try to scale this up the the task
definition themselves become a
bottleneck it's actually uh surprisingly
tricky to just sit down and think about
what kind of different things the robot
can do given its constraint workspace
constraint action space and so on
and if you want to do you know thousands
and thousands of tasks it's actually
difficult to come up with all of them
yourself
so then we thought well goal state is a
task right it's a it's an Insight that
that you already know as well
um so we can get rewards through
hindsight relabeling right we can
relabel the
um the episode and then set that the
reward for accomplishing the the last
state is just one everything else is
zero and this way we can get lots of
different tasks right like every episode
would give us a task a task could be
just defined by the goal image
but then there's one more problem if we
do this then we'll generate only
positive examples right we'll only tell
the robot how to achieve something what
to do but we won't really tell it what
not to do
so in addition to this we thought well
let's employ conservative Q learning to
create artificial negative examples so
that we can tell it what not to do as
well
right so here's a little uh one second
there's here's a little GIF showing how
it works just
um but we'll go over over this in detail
but one second let's start from the from
the beginning
all right so we take an episode from
empty up this is the video of that
episode then we can take all the states
from that with an artificial we can
regularize our Q function based on
artificial negatives and we can take all
the subsequences relabel the last state
as the goal and then use that little
episode for the actionable models
training where we do offline
reinforcement learning
and actually the the infrastructure and
the algorithms that we use are very
similar to empty out except now this is
goal condition and we do this artificial
negatives and relabeling with the goals
all right
so there's a few more interesting point
about this
so if we learn something like this it
gives us something like a world model
like what you learn about in model-based
rail lectures right where it's
independent of the reward it's just a
model that tells you how the world works
so this is actually quite similar right
this this kind of gives us a functional
understanding of the world it tells you
that given my current image and some
image that I want to get to was the
probability that I will actually get
there right How likely it is that I'm
able to achieve that future
and it's task independent it's all based
on the goal images right there is no
tasks involved it's just images
but in addition to a world model it also
gives you an actionable policy so not
only it tells you well how probable is
it that I can get from this day to that
state but it can also tell you well
what's the action that will take me
there right like you can find the best
action according to your goal condition
queue function and take that action and
that's the best action that the model
thinks will get you there
and then in addition to this we can use
it as an unsupervised objective for
robotics or for reinforcement learning
right we don't need any supervision we
don't need additional rewards and so on
you can take any data set and just apply
it to it and just see what happens
and then we can use it for zero shot
visual tasks so we can present a goal
image that it's never seen before and
see how well it does but we can also use
it as an unsupervised free training that
we can then use further for Downstream
fine tuning
cool so let's see how it works
so we start with this offline data set
of a robotic experience
so these are just some trajectories that
we that we've collected in this case
these were
um precisely the trajectories that we
collected with with the empty out
setting
and then we can relabel all of these
trajectories and all of their
subsequences with goals and markets and
Market successes similarly to what
you're doing in homework 3.
so at this point we have all these
trajectories and the sub subsequences of
those but they're all successful right
so we have this problem that the Q
function just knows what to do
all right so to to resolve this we'll
use some of the instances that we just
got from offline reinforcement learning
we'll create artificial negatives and it
will work as follows
so right now we have uh only positive
examples we need some negatives
so employ this conservative strategy
where we say We'll minimize the Q values
of actions that we have not seen so very
similar to what cql was doing right
we'll just say that if I if these are
the actions that I have seen right these
are the actions that I just relabeled
these are the positives
I will also sample some actions that
I've never seen
and I'll just minimize the Q values of
them on those
but in particular I won't be just
sampling any action I'll be sample the
actions that the queue function
currently thinks are particularly good
right I'll be just pushing down on those
Peaks that we were talking about
so we'll sample contrast of artificial
negative actions and we'll sample them
according to the exponent of the queue
so we'll ask our queue function what do
you think about this action if it thinks
of it very highly then we'll push down
the value of it right it's very similar
to cql you can think of it as cql just
in the goal conditional learning
all right so we can take these relabel
sequences and add conservative action
negatives and Mark those as failures
and at this point we already have a we
can consider training a goal condition Q
function that should be able to
accomplish any goal that it's seen
inside the trajectory
all right
but there's one more little caveat so at
this point we'll learn how to get from
any point or from a starting point in a
trajectory to any goal in that
trajectory right so I can get from here
to here I can get from here to here and
from here to there
but I don't really know how to get from
here
to here for instance
right I don't know how to get from
beginning of one trajectory to the end
or the middle of another trajectory
we don't really know how to chain these
goals we don't know how to chain them
across the episodes we can so far have
been only doing it within an episode
right so so let's think about how we can
how we can do this are there are there
any ideas how we could how we could
accomplish this
yes
I'm gonna just hope that it generalizes
yes I think that's one option
um that you know maybe the goal that
we've accomplished in this trajectory
looks similar to the goal that we've
accomplished in this trajectory then for
generalized and it will work yes
this one
I see so if two states are similar for
within the same trajectory
I see we can merge two different
trajectories from those from that point
right so we would need to know which
states are similar right or find some
kind of similarity metric yeah I think
something like that could work yeah we
would need to probably find you know how
to how to tell whether two states are
similar or not but yeah that's that's
probably possible
any any other ideas
all right cool so this is actually a
practical problem that we had so we've
empty upped we collected trajectories
for two different tasks this is just an
example for two different tests so we
had a picking task and the picking task
would start with the arm being withdrawn
from the bin and it would end with the
arm having something in the grouper
right and that would be the end of the
picking task
and then we would have a separate task
called placing tasks so it will be a
separate trajectory so let's say this is
the picking task it would start at the
arm being withdrawn and it would end of
the image of the arm holding something
and then we'll have a second trajectory
a second task that was a placing task
which would start from the image of the
arm holding something in the grouper and
it would end with the arm withdrawn and
the object in the in the ball or
something like that
right so it would be a different
trajectory that now starts when this
other task ended and it ends in a very
different goal image
right so there's almost no intersection
between these two trajectories except
maybe you know the last image of this
one is similar to the first image of
this one sometimes not even that
all right so in that case we can't
really ask a robot to uh you know
starting from an arm withdrawal state to
put something on a in a ball because it
just it's never seen that that goal from
this initial state
all right so we'll do this through in a
procedure called goal chaining and it
will be very similar to to what you
describe
all right so we'll just sample random
goals random images from our data set
right any random image goes we'll just
sample random images from the data set
and then we'll recondition our
trajectory on that random goal to enable
chaining goals across episodes right so
we can just take our trajectory sample a
random State and just say well what
would happen if that trajectory is
conditioned on that goal state
yes there's a question
right so the question is what action do
you use because he just took a random
State and there was no action associated
with it yeah so we just use it as a
potential goal state so for the goal
State you don't need an action right so
our Q function the state action and the
goal so we just set the goal State for
the to random state but we still have
States and actions from our current
trajectory
all right
yeah most most of them will be negative
that's right
so now if a pathway if there exists a
pathway to that goal dynamic programming
will find will prop will find that path
and we'll propagate that reward
right if there is some similarity
between the states like you were saying
dynamic programming itself through
generalization will be able to find the
state and then say well the Q function
for this is actually quite high you can
get to that call right I found the
pathway through the episodes for
instance in the picking and placing case
I found that you know if you just
continue you will actually get to the
goal you want to and we'll find that
pathway and we'll set the queue function
correctly
but if there is no Pathway to the goal
as you said the conservative strategy
will minimize those Q values and then
because of that we want erroneously
think that we can get there even though
we can't
cool so now we can recondition on any
random goal and it should work
all right so we added these conservative
action negatives we added random goals
for gold chaining so we are now ready to
train a goal condition Q function and we
do this using
um continuous action Q learning like in
empty opt we already have these
conservative actions so so we can do
this we just condition an additional
goal image
all right so we talked about two
applications and first of them was gold
reaching right so we can see if we can
reach certain goal images
all right so let's try this and again
this is the exact same data set that we
use for MTF we didn't collect any
additional data
right so actually let me pause this for
a second
all right so here in the top right you
can see what the robot sees currently
this is the live stream from the camera
image of the robot and here in the
bottom right you can see the goal image
that we requested
right so here you can see that the goal
image we requested is that the robot is
holding a carrot inside its gripper and
the gripper is on the right so now the
robot will try to do anything it can to
get to an image that looks very similar
to this image so that doesn't only mean
that you know you have to pick the
carrot it also means that you have to
position your arm correctly so it looks
the same and all the other objects look
the same and so on
all right
all right so this is an example of
picking a current that seems to be doing
a decent job now we are asking it to
pick a grasped corn cob by showing an
image of that
it seems to be doing this as well now it
tries to do this with a broccoli
and then we can also do this container
placing so here we show an image of a
carrot being inside the container and
you can see that it puts the carrot
there and then it positions the arm so
that it's similar to the goal image
here we can also show the goal image of
a banana being in a ball and the robot
tries to accomplish that goal image
here it also moves broccoli into the
bowl and then it moves the ball a little
bit so that it matches the goal image
it can also do a rearrangement task and
it tries to do a decent job at it it's
it's okay where it moves one object to
be on the other side of the other
here it moves the carrot away from the
tomato and you can see that very often
it doesn't push the object it picks them
up and drops them which is very similar
to experiences that are the experience
in MTL for we are picking and placing
things so it's trying to stay within
this Pi beta distribution
here you can also move some cupcakes
away
move broccoli and banana
and then we also have we've also I think
maybe we'll see this next we've seen
some uh
you can see that sometimes it like it
tries to push it over and over so that
it gets closer to the goal image
and eventually it almost gets there and
then we also tried to to test it on
objects that it's never seen before so
we've never seen the Silver Spoon before
but it seems that it can still kind of
figure out what the actions would take
you to this gold image that also
involves the Silver Spoon even though
you've never seen that silver spoon
before
so it pushes the spoon towards the ball
this is the same within another example
of an unseen object in this case it's a
fork
that is being moved towards towards the
cupcakes
and then and then we try to categorize
some of these results and we kind of do
this post-factum so you know we just
look at them and kind of try to see what
what these would correspond to and we
didn't try to measure the success rate
so for instance grasping gold images we
get to 92 for rearrangement 74 and
container placing 66 yep there's a
question
correct so the question is how does the
robot decide to start moving so it has
an additional action which is called the
terminate action so if it sends that
action that means it terminates and then
we decide the reward
all right cool and here it also plays
with some another unseen object and this
is a deformable object that is actually
quite tricky to manipulate and it's
never seen this before but you know
folks around and tries to do something
with yes
foreign
address
um yeah so in this case we are manually
doing this which kind of you know
defeats the purpose of the entire
exercise right because you have to
accomplish the task first to show it to
robot what you wanted to do and then it
does it again
um but it's mostly to show that this
unsupervised objective seems to be
working right like it seems that it's
going to accomplish certain goal images
however as an interface it's not a great
interface right it might work in some
cases maybe you want to take a picture
of a clean room and you want to ask the
robot to always bring it back to that
state that it doesn't make sense maybe
for tasks like that where you know you
need to move certain thing to a certain
other place and then you have to do it
yourself first
um
right cool so we talk a bit about how it
can reach goals and it's not the best
interface but we also before talked
about how it can be used as an
unsupervised pre-training for Downstream
tasks right we can kind of use it on any
data set let's just unsupervised
pre-train on everything and kind of see
how it does uh when we fine tune it to
something we care about
all right so we do this in simulation
first
so here we did it in two different ways
we either use it as pre-training so we
pre-trained and put this goal condition
queue function with actionable models or
as an auxiliary objective right so we
will be training both at the same time
the task and action model
or we can just not use it at all
so for simulation tasks these are the
results so we can see that by using the
pre-training mechanism or auxiliary
objective we get to a higher not only to
a higher reward but we also get there
much faster
so it seems that this functional
understanding of the world that we got
for maximum almost actually helps for
Downstream tasks for Downstream fine
tuning
and then we also tried it on on real
world data where we have very small
amount of data for a particular task and
for these tests if we don't pre-train we
get very very bad performance with free
training we can get to reasonable
performance and we can continue fine
tuning to get better and better
all right so we talked about offline RL
problem formulation why it's important
we talked about some solutions to it and
then we used some of those insights to
to think a little bit about how to share
data between the Fantastic multitask RL
and then finally how to do offline goal
condition reinforcement learning which
removes a lot of the obstacles from
reinforcement learning pipeline that
allowed us to use reinforcement learning
on big data sets without any rewards
tasks and so on
and uh for next time on Wednesday we'll
talk about long Horizon tasks how we can
solve them with hierarchical
reinforcement learning with skill
Discovery and as a reminder homework 4
is due next Monday I'm happy to take any
questions but thanks to all of you for
your attention